الحقيبة الأكثر أهمية في
العالم
التي يحملها الجيش والتي لا تبعد كثيرًا
عن
رئيس الولايات المتحدة ، غالبًا ما
تسمى كرة القدم النووية ،
وهي تحتوي على
معدات
وسلطات سرية للغاية يحتاجها الرئيس
ليأمر الجيش بإطلاق
سلاح نووي
على  في يوم التنصيب هذا مع تخطيط الرئيس
ترامب
لمغادرة واشنطن مبكرًا
وعدم حضور أداء اليمين لجو بايدن ،
سيكون هناك كرتا قدم نوويتان
والتحدي
المتمثل في ضمان سيرها بسلاسة ، واحدة
لجو بايدن في واشنطن
العاصمة في اللحظة التي يصبح فيها رئيسًا
واحدًا  رافق الرئيس ترامب إلى
فلوريدا
حتى لم يعد لديه سلطة وسلطاته
النووية معطلة ، تساءلت نانسي
بيلوسي عما إذا كان
ينبغي أن يتمتع ترامب بالسلطة
لشن حرب.
ضد هذا
الرئيس الخطير الشروع في
أي أعمال عدائية عسكرية أو
شيء من هذا القبيل  أسوأ من أن بيلوسي
قالت مؤخرًا
إنها تحدثت إلى الجنرال مارك ميلي ،
رئيس هيئة الأركان المشتركة
حول الضمانات المعمول بها
للأمر بضربة نووية ،
يقول كبار المسؤولين العسكريين إنه في حين أن
الرئيس لديه
السلطة الوحيدة لإطلاق أسلحة نووية ،
فإنه لا يمكنه القيام بذلك بمفرده
إذا أطلق الخصم صاروخًا
على
الولايات المتحدة ، فسيكون الرئيس على الفور على
شبكة اتصالات سرية يتلقى
معلومات استخباراتية دقيقة تلو الدقيقة
وتوصيات حول كيفية المضي قدمًا ،
فهناك ضمانات ضد
أوامر الهجوم غير القانوني سواء كانت
نووية أو
تقليدية لتكون أوامر قانونية  يجب أن
يكون لديك هدف شرعي
وهدف عسكري واضح واستخدام
القوة النسبية ، فالجنرال الذي
قاد الأسلحة الاستراتيجية مؤخرًا
وهو الآن
رقم 2 في البنتاغون يصر
على أن الجيش
لن يتبع الأوامر غير القانونية من أي
رئيس غير قانوني ، تخمين ماذا سيحدث
قل لا  سأقول السيد الرئيس
أن هذا غير قانوني وخمن ما هو
سيفعل ، سيقول
ما سيكون قانونيًا وسنأتي بخيارات من مزيج
من القدرات للاستجابة مهما
كان الوضع وهذه هي الطريقة التي
يعمل
بها.